[Music]
the playboy mansion
classy never heard of it what do you
guys think goes on there
probably everything now or back then
actually i do want it i think
ejaculation probably now very basic i
thought they sold it they did yeah now
that hefner is dead i think yeah but but
then oh no actually before before he
died they sold it but the only provision
was that hefner wanted to live in it
until he died yeah yeah i know the
boring stuff let's just get focused on
what what yeah
orgies
[ __ ] in the grotto parties hot chicks
[ __ ] they probably bring a lot of
celebrities michael bay showing off his
six-pack abs is what i hear all the time
yeah i don't know
understand he leaves his shirt open he
has [ __ ] six-pack abs he's rocking
around all the time nick's like how did
i not see this video yeah like what dude
because you know they're they're they're
adding gay a lot of gay like so playboy
used to be you know like pretty much
four straight men the phrasing just made
me laugh yeah they're adding gay gay
hey you guys hear this
bret man rock was the first dude on
there
rock yeah there's like nope man
there's guys
there's gay guys
they're acting gay
they're did you hear me
that play
boy now
it's an evolution you know
so the evolution of strait is gay
he said the evolution
i was thinking about pokemon
what
alright so
a playboy bunny reveals
some of the strict rules while living in
the mansion what are those rules right
can't eat too many cookies from the
kitchen for being a
girlfriend of hef
there are rules about things like that
yeah but you know to get into a former
playboy model has opened up about what
it's like living in the infamous mansion
including a number of strict rules that
women had to follow i bet it's weird
this girl's name is jenna bentley from
montana gotta shave your puss puss huh
resulted in the bunny it's rewarded like
that in the contract you could just say
[ __ ] right now
remember there's a there's a playable
mansion that actually means
and then there's also a bunny house
that's right next oh yeah i heard about
that so so this chick jenna she lived in
the bunny house uh which was next in the
mansion for a year between 708 is that
the real real spot like that's the more
exclusive like everyone can walk around
the mansion but the bunny it's probably
where the girls live let's get into it
uh she was 18 years of the time said it
was a dream come true for her to live
there at the resident residency but it
wasn't a complete free-for-all okay so
some of the rules in terms of how strict
they can get um
sorry
this was just bringing out asian gourd
sounds and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's ambiance people got a gong that was
trying to meditate in here and [ __ ] yeah
then i'm trying to center my inner peace
and [ __ ] before you know it he's got
that that buddhist bowl
ooh playboy
i was thinking about michael bay the
whole time
meditation nick dude
so they had a uh 9 p.m curfew oh that's
awful a 9 p.m curfew and if you didn't
make it into the house by the 9pm curfew
you
slept on the lawn what see there's
always some weird that's [ __ ] weird
she says they were very strict about it
if you missed the curfew you're sleeping
i'm assuming the house has so much [ __ ]
you don't really need to be out by nine
that sounds like a cult yeah bro what
you can't justify that a 24-hour kitchen
a 24-hour kitchen with cookies
everywhere look i'm pretty sure though
i'm pretty sure the whole you're really
about to cook
for the second time you got cookies
girls what else you need bro i want to
live in there and eat the cookies it
sounds like a like some college dorm
room [ __ ]
they weren't allowed to have boyfriends
like even meeting boys was an immediate
kick out of the of the body that makes
sense
former model did say that uh what she
got in return was unbelievable the place
had movie theaters animals trampolines
stylists
i guess i wonder for what
hey i would start jumping on a
trampoline these trampolines everywhere
but you're hitting cameras everywhere
too [ __ ] getting content at every
single
i moment thought it was weird that there
was [ __ ] trampoline in the bathroom
like when i'm getting chased there's
just a bunch of showers just
white t-shirts with a bottle of water
right next to the white t-shirts and
trampolines she says it was a real-life
barbie playhouse there were servants
doing all the cooking and cleaning there
was a phone that we called dial a dream
because you could press zero and ask for
anything you wanted anytime day or night
like if you want to mcdonald's
if somebody would go out and get it see
you could be in by nine you can call
anything damn so you could get like a
giraffe if you i just want a [ __ ]
girlfriend they already had drafts there
i don't think you would dial up for us
that's pretty tight actually she said
speaking about the party she said i mean
people think they were wild but they
were wilder than you imagined uh at one
party she saw angelina jolie tommy lee
pam anderson dennis rodman like the
parties were crazy and they're all
[ __ ] each other she would and she
would often walk around with trays of
party favors
it's in quotations so i'm guessing drugs
yeah interesting uh she said i never had
sex with hef ever but i did uh once walk
in on him having sex i obviously can
never say who it was with all i can say
is that there were four people including
him wow
he has three girlfriends all at any
given year
at any given he had girlfriends and
wives
i think he just had apparently he had
one wife oh maybe he got remarried then
i don't know i thought he had one wife
like actual wife and then a bunch of
girlfriends or something i don't know i
know he had girlfriends and wife wives
uh but they all lived in the main house
so there are three main rooms in the
house for his girlfriends and wives and
the rest of the girls lived in the bunny
house and stuff like that whoever were
playmates of the month though like
herself who was miss april back then you
could stay in the in the actual mansion
for an entire year for free wow and you
would help out with help out with body
paintings press release going out with
hef stuff like that um and shoes
confessing a lot of girls try to get
close to have so they can get more money
but when she was around shoot like you
know back in the 80s and 90s it wasn't
really about having sex with any of the
you know he wasn't about having sex with
any of the girls he was just
i'm guessing he was having sex with
everybody else realistically
um she just said he would shuffle around
in his uh slippers bless his soul i
think all the blondes just looked the
same to him by that point yeah you saw
he's definitely he's gotta be outsexed
oh and also he's old as [ __ ] so like
dude that dude was probably freaking
forgetting he was like ah yeah cause
that era he was already pretty
grandpa-ish right he was fighting dust
yeah even when he was tv show he like
dance dude as old as [ __ ] bro
he for sure was far and dusty he was
busting dust too for sure
busting busting down apple was busting
protein powder dude you probably can't
even get the whole dick hard at the same
time it's probably like soft here but
hard here or harder but still softer the
hard regions yeah
but by that point though like a half
burrito no it's like that it's like that
thing that implant you can get where you
like squeeze a nut and then it inflates
or whatever no way yeah it's like an
implant oh yeah we talked about it
imagine though like all right so it's
already hard getting hard when you're
that old right but then the [ __ ] that he
has to do because of all the experience
that he's had because you have to beat
what you have if he's had [ __ ] orgies
with the top-notch women yeah and
they're like he could have five of them
more than one
then what then what's next what's the
next level [ __ ] elephant is that what
the zoo animals were
the gay boy mansion that's nice right
they got gay now right they got gay
they're acting gay they're adding gay
that's the evolution that happened after
half left
the d evolution yeah it was a little too
late one generation two yeah he missed
it dude he was holding on that was like
his dream he was waiting for that
transition and it came too late you
think the world wasn't ready at the time
do you know how old he died it's like 80
something right not sure i just know he
died in 2017. i guess i could look it up
but i'm gonna put my money down for like
83. make guesses right now because i'm
sure the past seven yeah i'll go 86.
damn 91. whoa
was [ __ ] in the 90s damn that's
pretty good you think he was still
[ __ ] the last two years of his life
he was getting he was for sure sucking
if bretman was on it does that mean that
food's showing bret man [ __ ] butt i
don't think they show me look at that
should i look up brightman rock's
playboy spread and he's yeah like is he
showing nudity no they stopped doing
this before dudes yeah they stopped
doing news like two years ago
oh really yeah they're trying to be
classy or something they're trying to be
like esquire mag or something probs yeah
i'm sure there's a marker for it now
it's probably easier to sell across the
broader square starts doing nude but
that's like then that's like maxim
yeah yeah it would be but maximum in
other countries has nudity
what i thought maximum here at nudity
i've never bought one but what i thought
they did i didn't know maximum had news
not when i was buying them in high
school but other countries like
different magazines like fhm will have
nudity really yeah different different
countries different standards for that
huh our standards suck yeah we're the
most uptight for sure you guys know
brentman rock
not tight tight well he wanted your
tight butt i know like he did get him on
the [ __ ] i tried to he's so busy yeah my
wife's a big fan every day she shows me
new bretton rock videos and he's awesome
he's great i love him he doesn't love me
you know what's funny is that bart and
geo both tried to talk to him and he
gave jill no talk and you could split it
with bartlett hell yeah dude funny
that's like on point that's like on
brand correct yeah but it's just super
it's still super funny he's just being
professional he's like geo woman not on
brand let's talk with bart he's such a
professional beefcake bart yeah beefcake
bar
warren buffett bert quan dude bert
[Music]
you